[Music]
forget about it humphrey kate's an alpha
now and you're an omega
we're friends okay
exactly
just friends
end of story you better set your sights
over there
reba and janice
the veggietarians
[Music]
hello and welcome to a new episode of rt
essentials i'm mark ellis making a good
animated movie seems like a simple
enough formula includes some colorful
characters and silly humor for the kids
throwing a few fun pop culture
references for the parents and when done
right they'll make you a boatload of
money for years to come with sequels and
series and toys oh my
but they're not always done right and
end up being critically panned sending
your potential cash cow franchise back
to the farm as fast as you can say
direct to video sequel and now we're
talking about some of the most rotten
animated films both rotten on the tomato
meter and with a green bucket audience
score and when we're done you can go
check these out for yourselves and then
tell us just how right or wrong we are
because you know that we love that here
we go shark tale
hi i'm lenny
oh little buddy did i scare you i'm
sorry wake up wake up okay don't worry
about it i'm going to get you out in a
jiffy you just keep holding your breath
a little warming
ah i'm coming frankie i'm moving come on
bob's waiting
here we go
gotcha okay buddy you're free now escape
go just go cry freedom
let's dive in head first and swim around
with the first film on this list 2004's
shark tale this one has a stacked cast
of voices including will smith jack
black robert de niro renee zellweger
angelina jolie and yes martin scorsese
and smith who wouldn't do another
animated flick for 15 years plays a
pint-sized fish named oscar who is
looking to improve his social status
aren't we all so when the son of a mob
boss is accidentally killed oscar takes
the credit and eventually becomes the
target of said mob boss voiced by you
guessed it robert de niro who actually
replaced the previously cast james
gandolfini in the part the film's
release was moved up a month in 2004 to
avoid competing directly with pixar's
the incredibles and it seemed to work a
bit because despite the rotten rating
sharktail went on to make some decent
money around the world and was even
nominated for an oscar for best animated
feature of course it lost out to what
became the very certified fresh film the
incredibles lola
we meet again you know shark slayer
there's only one thing i like better
than money
revenge oh i'm in love
your shark slaying days are over
and there ain't nothing you can do about
it
but one of the major criticisms
surrounding sharktail was its use of
italian-american stereotypes and after
the anti-italian defamation league
protested the film's release dreamworks
responded by changing the name of peter
fox character from don brizzy to don
feinberg which was ultimately deemed
unsatisfactory to go along with that the
consensus from critics is that shark
tale is derivative and full of pop
culture in jokes with a lot of critics
saying it's not actually fit for kids to
begin with including roger ebert who
said that since a target audience is
presumably kids and younger teenagers
how many of them have seen the r-rated
godfather and will get all the inside
jokes well mr ebert it appears the
answer was
not very many you were probably on to
something
planes
thanks guys
wait
yeah that's your name that's some
supersonic sewer sauce man i thought
about a sticker bunch was bad man that's
got nothing on you
you just nasty and that's delicious you
need to go home wash up
twice
whoa coming in for a rotten landing as
the next movie on this list is 2013's
planes this film features dane cook as
the voice of dusty a small town crop
dusting plain with a fear of heights but
who dreams of one day competing as a
high
air racer so he turns to skipper a naval
aviator voiced by stacy keach who helps
dusty try to achieve his dream the rest
of the cast includes stars like anthony
edwards julia louis-dreyfus val kilmer
terry hatcher and priyanka chopra in her
hollywood debut and planes is actually a
spin-off of pixar's cars franchise
although it wasn't produced by pixar it
was however co-written an executive
produced by john lasseter who directed
the first two cars films and was the
creative head of both pixar and walt
disney studio animation at the time but
the only crossover between the two
includes a couple of minor characters
from cars tunes a series of shorts and
brent musberger as brent mustang burger
who was in cars too dusty i cannot bear
the thought of competing without you hey
that's the wing of a t-33 shooting star
when the great mexican air force needed
help american t-33s came
they did not ask questions
they did not hesitate
they were there because that is what
compadres do and what's that that is my
lunch don't touch but the wings are
yours planes came from disney tunes a
division responsible for mostly
direct-to-video releases but they
decided to send this one to theaters
first where it actually pulled in a
decent hall the 2014 sequel planes fire
and rescue also went to theaters and is
also coming in rotten and predictably
the critics were not feeling this one at
all jen cheney of the washington post
said it's like every other kid-friendly
life-coaching story about an
underestimated underdog and variety's
justin chang called it overrun with
broad cultural stereotypes and perhaps
most importantly as a critic's consensus
called it this was a quote disney
disappointment so much so that it sits
at number 70 out of 71 on rotten
tomatoes list of all the disney animated
theatrical movies ranked by tomato meter
they're called stats folks and boy do we
have them in bushels alpha and omega
where do you think you're going humphrey
you know the rules
you're not allowed to howl with her
she's an alpha
we can eat together but we can't you
know
how together guys i know i i was just
kidding
cheer up buddy you still got us friends
the next installment on this list of the
most rotten animated films is 2010's
alpha and omega this movie is loosely
based on the story of romeo and juliet
and revolves around two young rocky
mountain wolves named humphrey and kate
voiced by justin long and hayden
panettiere who fall in love with each
other despite being from opposite ends
of the past christina ricci danny glover
and dennis hopper in his final
performance prior to his death round out
the main cast the film was released in
3d and after a rough opening weekend
with just nine million dollars made at
the box office it kicked off a stretch
of five straight movies released over
seven months that would set the record
for the worst debut for a 3d movie a
list that's topped off with hoodwinked 2
hood vs evil which i have a feeling
we'll get to a little later why are you
looking at me like that
[Music]
unbelievable they have missed the trend
[Music]
or not
alfin omega was originally intended by
writer steve moore to be a bit darker in
tone and with a bit more serious story
the lions gate was looking for something
aimed more towards children which led to
the original script being rewritten
didn't seem to work though according to
critics like sherry linden of the
hollywood reporter who said it was
abounding and dumb jokes that kids are
bound to like but sometimes too scary
for very young viewers on top of that
the overall consensus from critics also
called out alpha and omega's bland
visuals and dull predictable plot so in
spite of the negative reviews or maybe
because of those bad reviews the film
has gone the way of the direct to video
franchise cranking out eight sequels in
the 12 years since its release there's
been a lot of math on that one sorry i
thought way too hard ice age collision
course will you be i'm gonna stop you
right there i'm breaking up with you
what but i planned our whole future our
wedding
our kids our burial plots how you doing
are you crazy we've only had one vape it
lasted 14 minutes yes but it felt like
20.
ah i can't a ring i mean i like the ring
but no i can't you're too clingy how is
this clinging barreling towards the next
spot on this list is 2016's ice age
collision course this marks the fifth
installment in the ice age film series
and not only is it the longest in the
franchise it is also the lowest scoring
on the tomato meter where each film has
been on the decline since the original
and only certified fresh installment ice
age released way back in 2002. many
stars including ray romano john
leguizamo jennifer lopez and queen
latifah reprised their roles from
previous films with newcomers like adam
devine jesse tyler ferguson and jessie j
joining the fun this time scrat is
accidentally fired off into outer space
in an abandoned spaceship that guy will
do anything for an acorn which sends a
giant asteroid heading back the other
way towards earth collision course
parody sci-fi films like alien the
martian and gravity and perhaps to
finally write the ship and be more like
the first film of the franchise the idea
for this one actually came from a scene
in ice age where the characters see a
spaceship encased in ice in a nice cave
[Music]
[Music]
but none of that quite worked the film
fell short of its 105 million dollar
budget at the united states box office
eventually pulling in a profit with
overseas ticket sales but still
finishing as the lowest grossing movie
of the franchise the critics consensus
calls collision course unoriginal and
unfunny offering further proof that not
even the healthiest box office receipts
can keep a franchise from slouching
toward creative extinction
ouch
this is backed by critics like peter
travers of rolling stone who called it a
loud lazy laugh-starved cash grab and
katie walsh of the l.a times who said
it's a watered-down entry that cynically
exploits its target audience by serving
them scraps and calling it yummy
and now i'm just hungry for scraps the
nut job wait we don't know what that is
andy i am in charge proceed my dear
oh
my god
i have been trained in mouth-to-mouth
resuscitative measures
she's fine and cracking into this list
next is 2014's the nut job this rotten
animated film stars the voices of will
arnett brendan fraser catherine heigl
and liam neeson among others in it
arnett plays surly an exiled squirrel
who destroyed the winter food supply of
his fellow park residents and tries to
redeem himself by raiding a nearby nut
shop which happens to be a front for
mobsters looking to rob the bank next
door did we get all that the nut job
pulled in a modest 121 million dollars
at the worldwide box office against the
budget of 43 million and despite the
negative reviews that was enough for a
sequel the nut job 2
nutty by nature which was released in
2017 and is only slightly less rotten on
the tomato meter but it's got to get
extra credit for the reference to 90s
rap group naughty by nature right and
speaking of budgets the 43 million
dollars for this made it the most
expensive animated film to be
co-produced in south korea which could
be why south korean music star sai makes
a cameo appearance as himself during the
end credits along with his hit song you
guessed it gangnam style you know the
one come on hit the music no
not dancing today
sorry kids like i love this stick i do
not know how to record this [ __ ] let go
of this all right fine
hey shirley
what'd you have for breakfast and while
some might argue that the mere presence
of that song is the main reason for the
rotten score it was probably some other
factors as well because along with
drawing some not so favorable
comparisons to other rodent-based
animated fare like ratatouille and over
the hedge a common theme among movie
reviewers is what the critics consensus
calls an unlikable central character
bill goody koontz of the arizona
republic wrote that arnett is a great
comedic actor and acidic wit but here
his surly is just a selfish jerk and
michael phillips of the chicago tribune
added that the nut job fights its
protagonist's own charmlessness from the
first scene dougal
bravo my friends i always knew you could
do it but we thought you were dead dead
nonsense dougal everyone knows that
after winter it's time for us
next on this list of the most rotten
animated films is 2006's dougal with a
voice cast that includes names like jon
stewart william h macy jimmy fallon
whoopi goldberg judy dench and john
krasinski this movie follows a talking
dog and his friends as they fight to
stop an evil wizard from starting
another ice age in the enchanted village
they call home dougal actually began as
a french language film released in early
2005 with a recast english language
version coming two weeks later into the
uk called the magic roundabout which is
fresh by the way but for the american
version the script was largely rewritten
and the voice cast with the exception of
ian mckellen and kylie minogue
re-recording her lines with an american
accent was replaced the result is a film
that is hovering around single digits on
the tomato meter with plenty of bad
reviews from critics and fans if you
want further evidence dougal was
nominated for multiple stinkers bad
movie awards including worst picture and
one two for worst animated film and
worst supporting actor for chevy chase
i'm guessing those don't make it into
the trophy case
oh look we got bone thugs and harmony up
in here
scary red eyes look at all dawn of the
dead and everything anybody know karate
uh i train with morpheus i know kung fu
john woo
judo kendo taekwondo wu tang clan and uh
chai tea
on top of those honors this movie also
landed at number five on eberton roper's
worst of 2006 list and also many other
worst of lists that year along with
being named the worst animated movie
ever by screen rant in 2015. the most
common consensus from critics is that
dougal was overloaded with pop culture
references ones that didn't really age
well but lacking in compelling
characters and plot with dvd talks randy
miller saying that it's like shrek
without the occasional bit of charm and
surprise
hoodwinked two hood versus evil
excuse me did i just hear your tiny
little voice correctly
did you just come into my house hassle
my hop interrupt my dinner and tell me
my hands are dainty
i eat sandwiches bigger than you little
girl
the next spot on this list belongs to
hoodwinked 2 hood vs evil released in
2011. this film is the sequel to 2005's
hoodwink which is also rotten but just
not this rotten with two of the main
voice actors anne hathaway and jim
belushi not returning they were instead
replaced by hayden panettiere and martin
short who joined returning stars like
glenn close and patrick warburton plus
newbies like bill hader amy poehler and
chee chen chong in this one panettiere's
red character discovers that she needs
to team up with friends to try and save
hansel and gretel who've been kidnapped
by a wicked witch the original film
hoodwink was actually one of the first
fully independently funded computer
animated films with a budget of under 8
million dollars but earning over 110 mil
worldwide meanwhile hoodwinked two
and not so much after coming in at
number six in its opening weekend the
film pulled in just over 23 million
dollars across the globe and was unable
to earn back enough to cover its 30
million dollar budget the wrong house
again
that's not good a little faster there
twitchy
huh hey is it busted no no no no it
can't be broken we just used it this is
why everybody hires the three bears no
wait wait wait wait wait wait this is
this let's see hey wait where'd they go
oh look they're trying to get away not
by the hair of my chinny chin
oh
muffins but before they could even face
that crisis hoodwinked two was
originally slated for release in january
of 2010 but was eventually pulled and
shelved indefinitely however not before
burger king released the line of toys
that same month in support of the movie
uh that's not a whopper that's a
whoopsie it finally came out almost a
year and a half later joining a handful
of animated sequels that underperformed
and came up rotten that year like cars 2
cars 2's rotten i love that movie happy
feat 2 and alvin and the chipmunks
chipwreck as a result the consensus from
critics is that hoodwinked 2 is missing
the first installment's wit and
refreshingly low budget charm that
sentiment was echoed by critics like
michael phillips of the chicago tribune
who said it leeches the fun clean out of
the first hoodwinked and michael
o'sullivan of the washington post who
wrote that while the first film was
lifted out of mediocrity by an utterly
delightful storyline the sequel is a
flat plotting and largely mirthless
affair
delgo this is your ferocious yag
next up on this list is 2008's delgo in
a bit of and i know what you did last
summer reunion this movie features the
voices of both freddie prince jr and
jennifer love hewitt prince stars as
delgo a naive and adventurous teenager
who begins a forbidden friendship with
kyla played by love hewitt their
relationship causes the hostility
between their respective people to
increase opening the door for an exiled
ruler to try and reclaim her throne when
it comes to the failures of this film
while it was definitely panned by fans
and critics alike you need to look no
further than the box office where it was
one of the lowest grossing wide releases
in recent history at the time in 2008 it
was the worst opening ever for a film
playing in over 2 000 theaters
ultimately earning under a million
dollars and being pulled from theaters
after a week
oh you're alive
that was good enough to overtake dougal
as the lowest grossing computer animated
film of all time a title it still holds
and if you're one of those math loving
types i can tell you the delgo lost an
estimated
46 million dollars when it was all said
and done and some of the common issues
that critics had with delgo were
described as weak animation dull
characters and bad voice acting and
perhaps most importantly as usa today's
claudia pugh pointed out it's also
rather dark and convoluted for children
with stephen witty from the newark star
ledger adding there isn't enough action
for older children or silly humor for
younger ones the emoji movie morning mrs
t i see you have the little minis with
you
oh they're so
cute
[Music]
that is so adorable i can't take it
no i'll never get them to sleep stick to
your one face weirdo conveniently yet
and sincerely being texted to the next
spot on this list is 2017's the emoji
movie because someone just had to make a
movie about emojis we were given this
film that includes the vocal talents of
james corden anna faris christina
aguilera sophia vergara and sir patrick
stewart among many others the film
centers on a multi-expressional emoji
named jean who lives in a teenager
smartphone and is on a journey to become
a normal meh emoji just like his parents
that's something we can all relate to
believe it or not this rotten film was
at the center of a bidding war for
distribution rights with sony pictures
animation winning out over warner
brothers and paramount it was then fast
tracked over concerns that it would
become outdated as phone technology
continued to evolve from there it was a
bit of a rocky ride with the film's
trailers garnering an almost abnormal
amount of negative reactions across
social media then tj miller parasailed
into a press conference at the cannes
film festival to promote the film in a
stunted variety called slightly awkward
the emoji movie did make a little money
with 217 million dollars at the
worldwide box office on a 50 million
dollar budget but that didn't stop it
from being universally lamb basted by
critics and viewers hey jailbreak mind
if we join you yes that's the thing
about the internet that you never tell
if someone's being ironic or sincere i
sincerely unironically want you to go
away
[Laughter]
and while critics dissed aspects like
the humor the tone the plot the script
the use of product placement the lack of
originality i mean pretty much
everything one common issue with
multiple outlets was the film's negative
comparisons and similarities to other
animated movies like inside out toy
story wreck-it ralph and the lego movie
among others because of all that it was
frequently named as the worst film of
2017 and led the heralded razzie awards
with five nominations including in the
category of so rotten you loved it and
won four of them for worst picture worst
director worst screen combo and worst
screen play the first animated film to
win in any of those categories so you're
breaking new ground emoji movie and
because rotten tomatoes is hilarious the
critic's consensus for this one is
simply the no symbol emoji in place of
text
that's a good one i'm a comedian and
that's funny norm of the north oh my
five o'clock is here excuse me normie i
don't know why you spent so much time
and energy on these tourists the humans
won't destroy something they love
and they love
us
and finally the last movie on this list
like a north star that all the other
rotten animated movies were walking
towards it's the 2016 movie norm of the
north rob schneider provides the voice
of norm a polar bear who doesn't know
how to hunt but does have the ability to
talk to humans something he eventually
needs to save his arctic home from a
shady developer voiced by ken jong the
voice cast also includes heather graham
loretta devine gabriel iglesias and bill
nye this rotten film seemed a little
doomed from the start with several
delays and rewrites leading to what
became a six year long
at that point the studio decided to put
what was supposed to be a
straight-to-video release like the three
sequels that have followed into theaters
first but after opening over a long
weekend in january of 2016 alongside
films like 13 hours the secret soldiers
of benghazi and right along two norm of
the north was only able to muster a
sixth place finish on its way to
grossing around 30 million dollars
during its run against a 20 million
dollar budget
any last words before i eat you
[Music]
oh come on don't say that
you always know exactly what to say to
get to me
eat him eat him
along with that came a lot of negative
reviews from critics even holding a zero
percent rating on the tomato meter for a
while before i saw it no i didn't
influence the tomato meter but it did
eventually get all the way up to six
percent gripes from critics include the
adult leaning plot points about global
warming and real estate with whatever
eco message there is coming across as
rather vague and of course with plenty
of animated movies already taking place
in a similar setting norm of the north
threw some unfavorable comparisons from
critics like mark kermode of the
observer who said it plays like a
bargain-bin mash-up of tropes lifted
from happy feet madagascar ice age etc
and given how far we've come with
animated movies these days katie rife of
the av club said that in a post-pixar
world where audiences have become
accustomed to quality animated family
films it's a waste of money alrighty
well that does it thanks for checking
out our list of the most rotten animated
films but as we all know by now if you
really want to know just how rotten or
not these movies are there's only one
way to find out boom i just set your
weekend plans for you you are welcome
thanks for tuning in to rt essentials
i'm mark ellis and my emoji combination
right now is beach umbrella
dog and chocolate donut
yes the dog is gonna try to eat the
donut no i will not let her
you